andrew live
german thank you very much um
good morning and welcome to this
licensing subcommittee meeting
held on friday the 30th of april 2021
we're sitting today under the licensing
act 2003 to hear an application made
under said act
my name is councillor mark durham and
i've just been appointed chairman for
this meeting
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect on
the 4th of april 2020 in response to the
kobin 19
situation firstly could i ask everybody
present in this meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted
and your camera on when not addressing
the committee
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live
and recorded and by being present in the
meeting you are giving your consent
to being recorded members and officers
during each item please use the hands up
function of the meeting
to indicate if you wish to speak i will
then invite you at the appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating a point of order
or that you need to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions or any other purpose please
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please ensure you
reference a page
or paragraph number now if i might ask
the officers taking part in the meeting
to introduce themselves
and we'll start with mr derma please
good morning sir um my name is nigel
turmer i'm the lead licensing
officer um i'm acting on behalf of
council
thank you mr um next mr geller
damien geller lead specialist community
thank you ms latimer
good morning i'm lacy latimer and
licensing officer for the council
thank you mr quelch
simon quelch and i'm a legal advisor
morning members
good morning uh mr winter
are you there mr winter
just coming through mr winter could you
introduce yourself please
hi there yeah my name's danny winter
licensing officer at chancellor city
council also a licensing officer for
malden district council
thank you mr winter and miss casey
good morning bernie casey talked to this
morning's committee could i ask ms
haylet if she could please turn her
camera off until the
chairman calls her just for clarity in
the meeting
thank you thank you very much
are there any other officers present
please if you could introduce yourself
there are none thank you very much uh
now berna could you carry out a roll
call of members to confirm
who is in attendance
i don't think there are any thank you
chairman
members i will call your names in
alphabetical order starting with
counselor baron
counselor darren oh i'm sorry of course
i'm here yes
construct
thank you castle i am here
thank you council stilts i'm present
thank you very much thank you chairman
thank you um
uh next item um are there any apologies
for absence i don't think there are at
this stage
no chairman thank you very much indeed
item four
uh disclosure of interest to disclose
the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interest
other pecuniary interests on
non-pecuniary interests relating to the
items
of business on the agenda having regard
to paragraphs six to eight inclusive
of the code of conduct for members and
members you are also reminded that you
are required to disclose any such
interests as soon as you become
aware should the need arise throughout
the meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the hands up function now to
indicate
and i will invite you to speak
i don't think anybody is but i will um
declare a non-pecuniary interest in them
for openness and transparency i'm a
personal license holder and i have been
um prior to that a holder of a justice
is unlicensed and have been involved
with the licensed trade for in excess of
30 years
thank you very much so no other members
no cherry thank you very much indeed
so we move on to item five on the agenda
the application for a new premises
license the warrick arms 185
high street malden um
i refer everybody to the aid memoir
found on page two
of the agenda pac which has been revised
for remote meetings
which details the procedure we will
follow this morning
police can ask everybody that you have
read the officers report and appendices
and evidence submitted which has been
circulated prior to this meeting
should anybody have any late
documentation in support of a
representation
or the application this may only be
introduced with the consent of
all parties members could you indicate
or just uh confirm that you have uh
received and read all of the information
received yeah
received thank you very much indeed
members just a reminder if you wish to
speak on
uh this item please make this name by
using a hands up function
and i'll then come to you in turn please
keep your points
clear and succinct
okay
now uh can i ask the person's present at
this meeting to introduce themselves and
we will start um as usual with the
applicant
uh miss you turn your camera on and
introduce yourself please
is the camera come on come on okay oh
okay
hello um i'm kaylee whaler
i am the license holder and a director
of
kra partners limited
okay you're all using the same device
thank you um uh we got mr o'reilly there
yep morning robert o'reilly also
partnering curry
limit okay um do we have this clifford
here
i don't think we do at this stage no
chairman
okay so thank you very much
indeed i will now call on miss latimer
to provide a brief outline of the
application miss latimer
thank you chair purpose of this report
is to consider
an application for a new premises
licence having regard to representations
received
and the requirements to promote the four
licensing objectives
the prevention of crime and disorder
public safety the prevent the prevention
of public nuisance
the protection of children from harm
recommendation that the licensing
subcommittee determines the application
for a new premises licence
taking into consideration the options
that are available as detailed in 4.1
below
members are requested to consider an
application by
kra partners limited made under section
17 of the licensing act 2003
for a new premises license in respect of
the warwick
arms 185 high street malden essex cm95bu
have in regard to the representations
received and the requirement to promote
the four licensing objectives
the application for a premises license
was received on the 15th of march 2021
and correctly advertised by the placing
of blue notices at the premises
and publication in a local newspaper the
public notice was correctly displayed on
the premises for a period of 28
consecutive days
commencing the day after submission of
the application
the premises license application from
kar partners limited applies for the
below activities
the completed application form together
with a plan of the proposed premises as
attached as appendix a to this report
in processing this application the
licensing department in accordance with
the act
sent a copy of the full application to
each of the responsible authorities
detailed below
a response to the consultation has been
received from essex police who agreed
conditions with the applicant
a copy of the agreed conditions is
attached as appendix b
to this report no other comments were
received from any other responsible
authorities
17 representations have been received
from members of the public
the representations are attached as
appendix c to this report
members are advised that they have the
following options when determining this
application grant the application on the
terms and conditions applied for
grant the application on the terms and
conditions applied for modified to such
extent as considered appropriate to
promote the licensing objectives
refuse the application in whole or in
parts
the committee is reminded that the
applicant or any person making
representation in relation to this
matter may appeal the decision of the
council to the magistrate's courts
the following strategic themes underpin
the council's vision for the district
enabling supporting and empowering
communities to be safe active and
healthy
protecting and shaping the district and
balancing the future needs of the
community
meeting the housing needs of the
district and to be an organization which
delivers good quality cost-effective and
valued service in a transparent way
that concludes my report thank you chair
thank you very much miss latimer
unless members have any questions or
comments i will move on to miss whaler
to make an opening statement
ms whale it over to you
oh there we go um okay
um as we understand we are to make an
opening statement and to
question witnesses we have no intention
of putting any questions to witnesses
however in relation to this hearing
we do wish to reiterate the
preventatives we have put in place to
allow the
neighbors fears namely joining the local
pub watch
working together with the local
community and the police
paid license store staff will be
employed on a friday and saturday nights
including bank holiday evenings this is
to strengthen the application for the
later time openings we accept that given
the history that the neighbours have
gone through with the warrick arms
that it is a concern and therefore we
would ask the committee to consider the
time to be moved to midnight on a friday
and saturday evenings
including bank holidays which will be
covered with dwarf staff
the door staff will also prevent
customers from leaving the public house
with glasses
we have a strict rule in place where
drinks will not not be allowed
outside ever eradicating the neighbors
concerns for the protection of
children from harm by no longer have
being
concerns of broken glass the door staff
will also monitor
those coming into the premises and those
on the
premises as to their intoxication highly
intoxicated
persons are not welcome into a public
house as we intend on making the warrick
arms are friendly
and family pub during the day and early
evening
this includes drug abuse there will be a
strict no drugs policy
and should there be any drug use or
possession on our premises yes they will
be immediately removed and barred for
this foreseeable
we will have a strict rule of over 25s
only on our premises after 7 pm
we believe this would also have an
impact on crime and disorder
and lower the risk of any disturbances
occurring following the
public house closing for the evening we
have installed fully working and
recording cctv to act as a deterrent
as well as any issues occurring this can
assist in any investigation
if required there is also a police
surveillance camera situated on the
corner of victoria road
which faces and covers the front of the
warwick arms
these cameras are watched by authorities
at all times which will be further
supported by any incidents
in the premises which will result in us
also reporting
the incidents to the police and
assisting them in any way in any
investigation
we are also aware that currently due to
covet restrictions there is a no
standing policy in groups of six maximum
with a table service only
we intend on maintaining this service
once the restrictions have been lifted
there is a uh this also will apply
to our smoking area which is located at
the back of the property
smoking will not be permitted at the
front of the premises for our customers
only at the back and must be seated with
a
number a limited number of customers
allowed
outside at one time and there appears to
be a concern regarding music
we must stress that we intend to only
play recorded music with the volume
being low enough for our customer to be
able to hold a conversation
therefore we do not believe the sound of
the music will impact the residents
we do accept that due to cover
restrictions the doors
will need to stay open during this
climate but i do not believe
even with the doors open the level of
the music will impact the neighbors
there will also be signs around the
premises to remind the customers to
leave quietly and respect their
neighbours
in relation to the opening hours the
purpose of only
of our early opening hours is so that we
are able to provide breakfast lunch
and dinner to our customers this will
also include
afternoon teas platters grazer boards
and sunday roasts
we intend on making this a family-run
pub and changing the view
and the previous reputation of the
warrick arms and this is why we have
decided to take a different approach
as we have mentioned today and believe
this will be a new start for the warwick
arms and the locals
um could you advise if you wish to call
any witnesses
um to make a statement um
no witnesses no okay i think you have
two with you so
um just them too so
no i'm not calling them though okay
that's fine
thank you very much indeed uh members do
you have
any questions at this stage for the
applicant please
counselor stilts
thank you uh councillor durham can i ask
the applicant will the
music be played on their patio area
outside or is will it only be inside in
in the pub um
no it oh no it will only be
inside no music to be played outside
thank you councilman siddall
thank you chairman uh
i are you now saying that you want to
change your times
from one o'clock on fridays and
saturdays to midnight
is that is that what you said as part of
your presentation
yeah that's what we said and that's
obviously just taking into consideration
what the public wanted us to do
so we feel like if it's 12 o'clock um
it'll be more understandable for them
okay and that's just something that
we're willing to do
sure um in terms of over you say
after seven o'clock it's going to be for
over 25. how are you going to
police that how will you know whether
someone is over 25
by id in each and every person that
comes into the property and by having
door staff that will also id the members
of the public
okay so you're saying that you're a
you want to create a family run club and
a family orientated pub
if you had a group that's a family that
comes in for an evening meal
and there's an age range of individuals
in that group
do you then turn away those those
members of that family that are under
25.
so if they're coming in for dinner um
obviously
it's acceptable for them to be there
with their families
and then ask to leave after um but if
they come in with like a group of
friends
um for example and there's some of them
that are underage then they would
obviously not be allowed on the promise
of
on the premises uh yeah so
i i can see that you guys do that
however i can see lots of difficulties
in that
in in terms of managing that situation
um
and it's a bit of a contradiction in
terms of
of you know the message that you're
presenting to us
yeah i do understand that but um one of
the things we'll be doing so on a friday
and saturday evening when it is most
busiest we're not actually offering
dinner
and so food does stop at 2 30.
okay so so weekends there will be no
food it will just be drinking
yeah apart from sundays and there'll be
roast dinners all day and like obviously
lunch time up until 2 30 there's
lunch time snacks and like food
available
okay so in terms of making it in terms
of making it
family orientated that only applies to
the weekdays
no because families are obviously still
welcome to come
saturday sundays fridays but the food is
only finishing at lunch time until we
you kind of see how the food works there
where food's never been
run from that pub before we just kind of
need to build up the reputation and get
the word out so people know that we do
food
and i just can't see it being doable to
put it on full time when we don't know
if we will be busy enough so just
starting with a few hours it will then
be
looked at in like a month's time and to
then start doing dinners every day every
evening as well
so so you you said that you were going
to offer platters
and food and things like that but again
those don't apply at weekends
no yeah they can be so if it's like
platters afternoon teas and stuff they
could be booked in advance
and for whenever obviously people are
looking to go
okay all right that's that's fine
thank you um i have a couple of
questions
myself um quite clearly you're aware of
the history of
of the warwick yeah yeah have you
have you purchased the property or are
you leasing or renting it from the owner
renting you're renting from from the
the previous owner yes very much um
and um you said you are a personal
license holder are you a young
are you the only personal license holder
i am yes
okay and can i ask how long you've held
that license for
um
yeah six months i think six months and
can i ask what previous experience you
have in the licensed trade
um i've i've always worked in
public houses from the age of 13.
um and i've been in managerial positions
in bars restaurants so
can i ask you just to give me an example
of a licensed premises you've run
manage please um
um this the spread eagle in whittam
um it was a few years back now wasn't it
before i had children
and then since then i've worked at the
cherry tree in whittem
and okay
and one one other question uh the the
license application is for the playing
of recorded music
yes that will be via music system but
would you intend to
um put on discos maybe in the evenings
um no no it's it'd be for a laptop
um it's not from a jukebox or anything
it's from a laptop
so only we have control over the music
a book but played for a background music
system obviously
yes just through speakers yes yeah i
take it you're a word of aware of the
prs and ppl in that case
yes good okay thank you very much
indeed um
right members have you got any other
questions you wish to
ask um as there are no responsible
authorities present i
was going to ask uh the objector if
they'd like to make an opening statement
but miss casey i i don't think we have
ms clifford present do we no she
she obviously didn't manage to join the
meeting
okay all right so um we have got the
written
i i'm assuming uh the we have some
submissions that were obviously all
redacted i'm assuming that
uh one of those may well have been from
miss clifford is that
a fair assumption miss casey yes that's
correct thank you very much indeed
uh miss casey is there anybody else
that's wished wishes uh
indicated they wish to speak uh no
chairman
okay um right
uh so um miss whaler
is now an opportunity for you to make a
closing statement
um to the panel before we
uh chairman uh councillor stills did
just raise her hand
i'm sorry i i didn't i didn't say i was
busy reading councillor stilts
i said can i miss chairman can i ask mr
geller if we've done a noise assessment
on this property
hello councillor um right so from the um
checks that we've done i don't have any
details for any recent noise
assessments uh or historic noise
assessments nothing nothing has been
returned over to me
[Music]
clearly you know given the situation
pubs haven't been open um
so can i just ask ms when when you plan
to
um start operating this uh subject to
getting the license please
um we're planning on opening on the 15th
of may
15th or 17th
um 15th because we was going to invite
locals
to our outside area and just come and
meet us
um have a taster of food and
yeah okay okay thank you
um so yes ms well it now is your
opportunity and that's other members i'm
just looking nobody's indicating
um to make your closing statement please
um i believe that we've put forward
everything that we've wanted to say and
we believe that we have successfully
made arrangements to prevent any
concerns suggested
and we hope that you consider our
representations today and we thank you
for your time
thank you very much indeed um
members your last chance to uh
say anything or ask any questions of the
applicant or indeed any officers present
do any of the officers present wish to
make any comment or ask any questions
no comment from myself nigel dermot
okay i'm taking general silence as uh
just
chairman just one thing and maybe mr mr
winter or miss lacy will be able to
confirm this
so the the application for you now for
the premises license stands
as on friday and saturday closing
at 12 midnight so that presumably how it
works here
wouldn't it be mr winter or miss lacy
that the application
stands um amended
with that reduction it's not increasing
the amount of activity it's reducing the
amount of activity so that's okay
is that how you would view it i think
just for clarification chairman
hi uh mr quilch yeah that is how i would
view that situation yet
okay are you happy with that mr12 yeah
that's fine chairman yeah so that's your
application now that you're designing
you don't need to put any condition in
saying it's reduced to 12 o'clock that's
why i raised it
it just stands amended yeah thank you
very much indeed so in accordance with
point 10 of the aid memoir the meeting
will now close
members we will discuss the evidence and
representations made before reaching our
decision
all parties will be notified of the
decision within five working days of
this hearing
members are reminded that the applicant
and or any person making representation
in relation to this matter
may appeal the decision of the council
to the magistrates court
so if everybody is happy i will close
this meeting
and members
sorry my dogs are going mental outside
so um we are at uh
closing the meeting at 10 27
members please do not enter into any
conversation or discussion on this forum
leave the meeting promptly and you have
the meeting invite for the decision
meeting
and i will see you there very shortly uh
miss casey is it okay if we go straight
into that meeting
yes secretary chairman forgive me just
to
um i will only come in if chairman you
want me to come in and i
will leave you if you need me to to
obviously call me on teams
otherwise obviously it would just be the
four of you
um mr quoch um i i can't speak for the
other members but i would be grateful if
you could
attend that meeting okay okay chairman
i'm happy to do that
yeah okay members are you happy with
that yes
thank you very much indeed okay so i
closed this meeting what is now 10 28
thank you very much thank you very much
ms whaler for your
um for your input and uh as you've heard
you will be receiving the
um the judgement of this committee
within five working days thank you
thank you so much thank you